ce qui différencie le peuple français
emmanuel macron c'est que le peuple
français est un peuple profondément
politique est un peuple de raison quand
emmanuel macron n'ai jamais rien d'autre
qu'un vulgaire politiciens vous parliez
tout à l'heure du confinement du mois de
mars
le confinement du mois de mars était la
solution la solution d'intérêt général
et les françaises et les français l'ont
immédiatement compris comme cela et ce
qu'ils ont regretté
à ce moment là c'est que ce confinement
n'est pas eu lieu quelques jours plus
tôt ce qui aurait permis d'épargner bien
des vies et si ce confinement n'a pas eu
lieu plus tôt
c'est que monsieur macron était dans les
ces calculs politiciens parce qu'il
voulait absolument maintenir les
municipales alors même qu'il savait
qu'il savait même depuis des semaines
souvenez-vous de l'interview de madame
busin dans le monde qui dit que dès fin
janvier elle a prévenu l'exécutif delà
de la situation réelle et a dit que les
municipales par exemple ne pourraient
pas se tenir
on a bien vu à quel point le
gouvernement à retarder au maximum le
confinement à cause de cette de ce
rendez vous institutionnel électorale
que monsieur macron voulait absolument
absolument pas c'est donc je crois que
le peuple lui est capable de réagir et
s'il ya besoin demain d'un autre
confinement parce que la situation
l'exigé
les françaises et les français sauront
le faire par contre on n'oubliera pas
vous avez vu pas au printemps fleurir ce
hashtag sur les réseaux sociaux on
oubliera pas et c'est ça qui ressurgit
aujourd'hui pas plus tard que
en fin de semaine dernière il y avait
des auditions dans le cadre de
l'assemblée nationale où madame par lee
a été entendu et où on a appris que
madame par lee avait menti à propos des
militaires qui sont rentrés de one au
mois de janvier et qui n'ont pas été
testés alors qu'on ne savait même depuis
le début qu'il n'avait pas été testée et
pourtant elle disait le contraire
on sait que monsieur vérone depuis a
menti sur la question des des masques au
mois deux ans au mois de mars
on sait que madame busin elle-même a
menti donc aujourd'hui il ya une
fragilité dans la parole publique encore
plus une fragilité dans la parole du
gouvernement et de monsieur macro et je
crois que la grande force de ce pays
c'est que malgré ça s'il ya une décision
nécessaire à prendre les françaises et
les français seront capable de
l'accepter
après encore faudrait-il que le débat
puisse être organisé et que le
gouvernement ne fasse pas oeuvre
d'autorité ou d'autoritarisme
comme ce qui fait de plus en plus
[Musique]